Joker, the upcoming standalone from Warner
Brothers and DC starring Joaquin Phoenix,
promises to be a comic book film unlike any
other.
Inspired heavily by the works of Martin Scorsese
and co-starring his frequent collaborator
Robert DeNiro, Joker presents the story of
Arthur Fleck, a failed comedian with a troubled
inner life who becomes the Clown Prince of
Crime, the most feared figure in Gotham City's
underworld.
More character study than superpowered smash-up,
Joker is one of the rare comic book films
to receive an R rating.
With a property as iconic as its main character,
getting clearance to push the film beyond
the boundaries of your average superhero fare
was not an easy task for co-writer and director
Todd Phillips.
Talking with the Los Angeles Times, Phillips
explained why he decided to use the character
to tell a different kind of comic book story
on the big screen, and what it took to get
the green light to pursue his gritty, R-rated
vision.
Phillips explained that the inspiration for
the film came as he was attending the premiere
of his 2016 dramedy War Dogs in August of
that year.
Taking it all in, he couldn't help but be
distracted by a billboard for a big-budget
superhero movie which loomed over the area.
He didn't say which one, but as the Times
noted, this was right around the time Suicide
Squad opened, which happened to feature a
supremely divisive turn by Jared Leto as the
Joker.
Phillips may be known for comedies such as
The Hangover, but he's also a Scorsese disciple,
and said he had been disheartened by the last
couple decades' lack of in-depth character
studies for which the master filmmaker was
known such as 1974's Taxi Driver and 1980's
Raging Bull, both of which starred DeNiro.
As he regarded the billboard, the seed of
an idea was formed.
Phillips said,
"I knew that War Dogs wasn't going to set
the world on fire, and I was thinking, 'What
do people really want to see?'
The movies that I grew up loving, these character
studies from the '70s, you couldn't get those
movies made in this climate.
I'm staring up at this billboard and I said
to myself, 'What if you did a movie in that
vein, but made it about one of those characters?'"
"I'm an ideeaaaaa."
Perhaps inspired by the character's Suicide
Squad depiction, Phillips became focused on
the Joker, and as he discussed his idea with
the film's co-writer Scott Silver, the pair
were emboldened by the fact that the iconic
Batman nemesis had never received a proper
origin story in the comics, which was by design.
While various depictions of the character
including those in Tim Burton's Batman and
the TV series Gotham had settled on the "falling
into a vat of chemicals while escaping the
Dark Knight" tack, Phillips and Silver decided
that it would be much more interesting to
offer up their own version of the Joker's
origin, one far less fanciful and much more
grounded in reality.
Phillips said,
"We wanted to look at everything through as
real and authentic a lens as possible.
I don't believe that in the real world if
you fell into a vat of acid you would turn
white and have a smile and your hair would
be green."
"You idiot!"
Instead, Phillips went about reverse-engineering
the story, giving the Joker an origin story
that was slightly more realistic.
It was an enjoyable process.
According to the filmmaker,
"It was one of the most fun scripts to write,
because you were only breaking rules."
In 2009, Phillips made The Hangover for Warner
Brothers, and since that comparatively low-budget
comedy went on to gross an improbable half-billion
dollars worldwide, the studio's executives
were inclined to hear him out on his vision
for Joker, certain story elements of which
would require the film to carry an R rating.
But there were seemingly a million different
objections to the idea that had to be dealt
with before Phillips and his team were allowed
to proceed.
Complicating matters was the fact that a major
regime change had taken place at Warner Brothers
in the middle of the movie's pre-production.
Phillips recalled,
"It was a yearlong process from when we finished
the script just to get the new people on board
with this vision, because I pitched it to
an entirely different team than made it.
There were emails about: 'You realize we sell
Joker pajamas at Target.'
There were a zillion hurdles, and you just
sort of had to navigate those one at a time."
The process was difficult and frustrating,
but Phillips said it was worth it, and that
he's still kind of surprised that he got away
with it all.
He said,
"At the time, I would curse them in my head
every day.
But then I have to put it in perspective and
go, 'They're pretty bold that they did this.'"
Bold, yes, but it's shaping up to be a pretty
good call: Joker is the most highly-anticipated
film of the fall, and Phoenix's performance
is generating strong Oscar buzz.
It's a radically different approach to the
DC Comics properties than producers had been
pursuing with their shared universe, and may
represent a new way forward for the sometimes
embattled brand.
This fact isn't lost on Phillips.
Midway through Joker's production, he suggested
to Warner Brothers executives that they create
an entirely new label for gritty character
studies such as his take on the Joker: a new
banner called DC Black.
According to Phillips, they weren't immediately
on board.
He said the response was,
"'Calm down with the label — how about you
do one movie?'"
Despite the positive reactions, Phillips understands
that his interpretation of the Joker might
not be every DC fan's cup of tea.
That's just fine with him, because he knows
that his take on the Clown Prince of Crime
will in no way be the definitive one, and
it certainly won't be the final one.
He said,
"This will not be the last Joker movie ever
made.
It might be the last one Joaquin and I do,
but someone else is going to come along and
do another one, just like with Spider-Man.
So if you don't like this one, don't worry
it'll get reinvented again.
[...] They've done four or five versions of
the Joker in the last 25 or 30 years.
So why not do another one that's wildly different?"
Why not, indeed?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.